[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight things move fast in the
aoc generation history is 2017 so for a
little perspective we're gonna take you
back
29 years was still the modern era that
we still had air conditioning we still
had air travel 1990 America was
different in some ways though and here's
one of them in 1990 2245 people were
murdered in the city of New York
that's the highest number ever recorded
in any American city ever and it turned
out to be the peak of the worst crime
wave in our history
then Rudy Giuliani got elected mayor
policies changed and crime began a very
steep decline in New York by 2001 the
city of New York recorded just 649 MERS
a remarkable change really Michael
Bloomberg er became mayor of New York
the next year and made New York even
safer one of his main tools for doing
that was a policy called stop and frisk
essentially it was this the NYPD stopped
suspicious-looking people people they
thought look suspicious ask them
questions and sometimes search them for
weapons and illegal drugs not everyone
liked it ever but there's really no
debate about how well it worked it
worked well by 2013 Bloomberg's final
year in office New York City recorded
just 333 murders total all five boroughs
for the year it was officially America's
safest city it was a remarkable change
Mike Bloomberg was proud of that and he
was proud of stop and frisk today we
have fewer guns
fewer shootings and fewer homicides in
fact murders are 50% below the level
they were 12 years ago when we came into
office something no one thought possible
back then there is just no question that
stop question frisk has saved countless
lives and we know that most of those
lives saved based on the statistics have
been black and Hispanic young
not just most but the overwhelming
majority had been in that category now
again that was just 2013 not that long
ago you may even remember 2013 but today
Michael Bloomberg is trying to win the
Democratic nomination you'd think that a
party that claims to care about poor
people would reward anyone who makes
low-income neighborhoods safer but no
they hate him for it this is a policy
that overwhelmingly put black boys black
men and black and Latino men in prison
which was seen as a as a civil rights
violation this is a mayor that provided
over an administration that stopped and
frisked every black Latino and poor
person that they could it is a man who
actually ran New York City kind of like
a oligarch and ultimately supported and
defended a stop and frisk policy that
essentially mass incarcerated black and
brown people I have three words
stop-and-frisk that will be the thing
that will be the problem for Michael
Bloomberg he still defends his policy of
stop and frisk which impacted families
like mine it was my cousins and my
friends that were stopped on the New
York City subway system and racially
profiled and patted down oh yeah
it affected Alexandria Kazi cortezes
family cuz he Curtis Bailey grew up in
Westchester County New York in a town
that is more than 90% white but she's
telling us it's racist and amazingly
Mike Bloomberg seems to agree with her
the last spring Bloomberg blasted Joe
Biden for his Craven opening campaign
his apology tour where he begged
forgiveness for every good idea he'd
ever supported now it's Bloomberg's turn
to do the very same I got something
important really wrong
I didn't understand that back then the
full impact that stops were having on
the black and Latino communities I was
totally focused on saving lives but as
we know good intentions aren't good
enough back then I was wrong and I'm
sorry
sorry he's saying in the hostage tape
you just watched I was focused on saving
lives when I should have been affirming
the self-esteem of teenagers who carry
loaded Glocks in public that's what Mike
Bloomberg just told you that's what the
Democratic Party is making him say now
the remarkable piece of this almost
stunning if you think about it is it
this very same Michael Bloomberg one you
just watched apologized for stop and
frisk is also the single most aggressive
and free spending lobbyists for wait for
it gun control in America he would
disarm suburbia tomorrow if he could
much less rural America and yet now he's
telling you there was a moral for him to
allow his own Police Department the NYPD
to take thousands of illegal firearms
off the streets of New York this is
confusing his health
what's the reasoning here well there
isn't any policies like these and there
are many of them they're popular now
from allowing drug addicts to shoot up
on the subway to coddling vagrants as
they squat on the sidewalk outside your
house
these policies only make sense when you
understand in effect what is the bigotry
of the left what's the big tool that
despised normal people law-abiding
middle-class Americans enrage them if it
makes your life better in some
measurable way they're opposed to it
their sympathies are entirely with the
Destroyers